welcome back to las vegas now heart
disease is the number one burst defect
and leading cause of infant death so
findlay automotive wants to show their
support for the children's heart
foundation and we have tyler quarter
here
to tell us more about these efforts hey
tyler how are you today rocky i'm good
good to see you
happy st patrick's day happy st
patrick's day so
let's just start off with obviously you
guys do so much for the community but
this one
i'm sure is super dear to your heart
let's start with the numbers i know i
mentioned one but there's more
yeah so uh as you mentioned heart
defects is the number one
uh defect for
newborns and it's the leading cause of
infant deaths and it's
surprisingly 60 times more prevalent
than childhood cancer which
which surprised me and so uh it's
something that's
really out there and we want to talk
today about the children's heart
foundation because
they deal with this issue and they try
to help the families that that are
dealing with
children with heart defects wow so what
are some of the things that they do
for these families and tell us about
your partnership with them
yeah so we've been supporting them for a
few years and and
probably the thing that strikes me the
most is you think about being a child
with a heart defect or a parent who's
have a child that you have to
take to the hospital and so what the
heart foundation does children's heart
foundation is they have a lot of
services to help those families
with financial assistance number one and
then they have some cool programs like a
backpack program when you check into the
hospital
or the backpack with all the things that
you might need
you have a summer heart a summer camp
program called
camp men to heart where kids can get
together with other children that have
a similar issue probably my favorite is
what they call maggie's garden
and maggie's garden is where when the
child goes to the hospital
they get the opportunity to choose a toy
that's available there to kind of get
their mind off of the situation that
they're going to go through and this is
really important because
about half of these kids that have heart
defects are going to have an invasive
heart surgery at some point and
you know if we get their mind off it
help them through that hospital process
that's what the children's heart
foundation
is really trying to do wow and tyler i
know that the community our community
can help you guys
help support this cause as well let's
talk about the event coming up
yeah so this is and i'm excited about
this because
it's the first live event that's going
to happen in a long time they've been
putting together their uh every year
they have a what they call
walk with a harvard child it's a
fundraising walk
for the last year everybody's been
virtual on their events but they've got
it set up now i just got the information
on may 22nd they're going to have a live
walk
at craig ranch regional park uh pretty
soon it'll be available on their website
where you can sign up and register
go out and walk raise some money support
kids with
heart defects pretty excited about it
that's great anybody can come join
families
yep everybody formal walk team and you
can just go to the children's heart
foundation website it's not quite ready
yet
but pretty soon in the next few days i
think they'll have the registration info
up there
that's awesome thank you so much tyler
for everything you and finley automotive
does for this community we appreciate
you
that's awesome thanks rocky all right
see you later tyler friendly automotive
group thank you for being one of our
community pride partners las vegas now
we'll be right back